this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 18th of may the joint is
brought to you by expressvpn
you guys already know all about
expressvpn i talk about them all the
time on here you know how important it
is to protect your online activity from
guys who track
spy and profit off you but there's
actually another reason many of my
listeners love using expressvpn you
ready netflix
thousands of shows on netflix are only
available
outside the u.s so you need to change
your country to see them express vpn
reroute your data through a server
located
of your choice and let you control which
country you want netflix to think you're
in you want to be in [__] sweden
there you are you want to be in puerto
rico jumping up and down there you are
choose from over 90 different countries
so every time you run out of stuff to
watch
fire up the app
switch your country and hit connect i
wonder what happens if you put [__]
slinger poor in there whatever the [__]
it is singapore and it's not just for
netflix you can use expressvpn to unlock
other streaming services too
look there's a reason why expressvpn is
the number one rated vpn provider by the
publishers of the verge and your uncle
joey so do me a favor
visit expressvpn.com
joey j-o-e-y right now
and get three extra months of service
for free that's it it's that [__]
easy you think i'm gonna bother you on a
wednesday that's expressvpn.com
joey expressvpn.com
joey
take a chance with the dark web
and the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion the best i love him with all my
[__] heart you ready for this one i
had a cat that was [__] dying
wee-wee was not doing well until about
three [__] weeks ago
and then my wife broke out the cbd lion
cat cbd
she's out there scratching singing she's
back she's back it's been [__]
unbelievable and my wife cut her other
meds what am i saying that cbd lion
works for everybody whether you're a dog
or cat
a [__] human being
tip top magoo whether it's the gummies
whether it's the kinesiology tape
whether it's the bat ball the good thing
about cbd lion they have something for
you you just have to go online go to
cbdline.com right now read the third
party lab results there's something on
there for everybody i was telling
somebody a day maybe the gummies don't
work for you let me tell you something i
cut a piece of that kinesiology date i
put it on my shoulders and my knees and
i'm [__] fine for a couple hours
give it a shot go to cbdlion.com
read the third party lab results and
when you find something
push in joey and don't even get me
started on that delta nine cbd lions
relaxation to the [__] max
so do me a favor cbdlion.com
preston joey joint or church and get 20
off delivered to your house
cbdlion.com
code joey joint or church
20 now let's get this [__] party
started because it's a beautiful day to
be alive
hey how you doing
come on
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
do
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
the 18th welcome to uncle joey's joint
[__] been hot in jersey last couple
days
humid as [__] not my favorite weather
when i left jersey 40 years ago that was
guys as stupid as this sound yes
i had to leave because i was looking for
a new light but at the same time i
[__] hate the humidity i do not do
well
in [__] humidity you get this like i
took three showers yesterday three
[__] showers because i just felt
dirty you know what i'm saying and
somebody my wife said why do you take so
many showers because i'm a fat dude
when you're a fat dude you gotta stay in
front of it unless the tit sweat starts
to [__] stink up a little bit you
know what i'm saying so you got to stay
on top of it
but uh i don't give a [__] it's
summertime i don't i put my
thick hooded sweatshirts are gone now i
got the couple light ones left and in
two or three weeks those are
[__] will be gone too so it's
that time of the year celebrate what
scares me a little bit is that new
jersey i saw it today at the gym we got
3 200 cases of cobia i mean listen
nobody's dying nobody's going to the
hospital but it makes you think about
december so whatever plans i'm doing
this year december i'm not including
because the 3200
[__] uh new cases in may and people
are out what you're gonna be like in
[__] december
by that time we'll have another [__]
variant who the [__] knows so if i'm
just letting you know right now plan
ahead don't get too crazy in [__]
december the first week or so you could
mingle and after that
covert will be out who gives a [__]
anymore guys it's just a [__]
headache but it slows you down for a few
days but somebody was telling me now if
you have covert
you can still go to work with a mascot
if you're if you're uh whatever the [__]
vaccinated i don't know
that's what i heard i don't know how
[__] true it is but it's a new day
it's a new [__] week i'm excited
i'm doing a little comedy tomorrow night
15 minutes and i ain't [__]
i ain't gonna change the world but at
least i get to do some time get to try
out the new material i've been writing
get to see if this [__] still works for
uncle joey
and i'm excited about that that's it you
know
i miss the comedy store i miss my
friends you know i miss going down i
mean i got a new life now and stuff and
it's great but
from time to time you think of all the
people and what they're doing
and a lot of people still keep in touch
with me you know from time to time a lot
of people really do
like this week i talked to whitney a lot
you know i was saying uh
whitney was in town this weekend i was
gonna go see her
saturday night but i [__] my daughter
came downstairs we started talking she
busted out cherry italian ice
the guy who was picking me up was
running late so and i felt bad i called
her we spoke a little bit but last night
as you guys will hear later on whitney
went to a fox party monday night in new
york
and one of the kids the the guy that
took me remember i talked about mr t and
the church a lot mr t
mr t sun the guy who saved me who i
still talk to i still talk to mr t maybe
once a month mr t
whitney sent me a picture monday night
of her
with mr t's son nicholas and it was like
i looked at i thought what the [__] is
that that looks like nicholas so i
called nicholas and he texted me back
that he couldn't talk because he was at
a fox party obviously and then later on
he called me goes no i bumped into
whitney and i told him i was friends
with you and i told her that you used to
babysit me it was so [__] weird
you know i had no i couldn't go to a
rehab so i stayed with mr t and he had
two kids chris and nick
chris was like six and maybe nick was
like four and nick took to me when i was
you know 21. i like kids so i'm throwing
them around up in the air and [__] one
day i [__] we're playing and i throw
him up in the air and his head hits the
pipe in the basement [__] he's crying he
ain't bleeding or nothing but i'm like
that kid's not gonna have much of a
future with that [__] bangladesh well
he's [__] proved me wrong he's an
executive of [__] fox now he calls me
with [__] from time to time but i don't
want him to think that's why he's my
friend i love him like a nephew you know
but uh
i was talking to carmen morales you know
about two months ago we were just
talking about
she was shooting a special in new york
and she called me and she goes would you
like to come her ada
alfred robles they go you know come over
one night but i was busy i don't know
what i was doing but i thought about i
watched uh ada's special on hbo
max you know i think you could push it
up at any time and i was very proud of
her aydah was the girl that came on the
podcast
ate a star towards the end of the
podcast and then when she got home was
fully activated and she ended up in the
[__] hospital and she told the doctor
doctors like listen
just don't eat that stuff anymore drink
some water and get some rest and she
looked at the doctor she goes but doc
that's the first time i ate an edible he
goes sure it is and he just turned
around and walked out there and she's
like but it is it is
joey so anyway all those spanish dudes
got some hbo max love
and i got to tell you something i was so
[__] happy
when i see door people at the store
i know that they got a 50 50 chance of
making it
they really do
just because they're watching comedy
they're living it they're involved with
comedy and they're working on that
comedy that's a hell of a [__]
combination to beat you know i worked at
the store as an emcee i also worked the
store as a doorman
and it was great it was great to pay
your penance it was embarrassing when
the higher comics see you like you work
here you're like yeah and they're like
but
i think they still have a little bit of
respect for you somewhere they go you
know what it takes a lot to do what they
do and they stick around till three in
the morning and they get the spots if
somebody doesn't show up they get to
shine for 15 minutes so you see the
process
and it kind of makes you happy because
it would break most people
you know it would break most people but
when you i don't know what it is about
comedy i don't know if it's the same for
music i don't know what it is when you
love something so much that you forget
about everything else in life except for
that
that's got to be something [__]
strong and that's the way it was for me
so when i see those
girls you know when i got to the store
it was just door guys and door guys
would do all that stuff
but when i got there in 2014 you know
the world was changing they had some
door girls there and her jessica
wellington
j jesus trejo listen to all those names
these are names that were door guys at
the store and today they've all shot
specials or they've all got popular
[__] podcasts so what i'm telling you
is right just being in that mix is
really good for you it's like being like
for a kid to get really good in
basketball football baseball he would
have to go to a camp it's a one week of
24 7. you just focus on that particular
sport
think of your focus on that same thing
in that realm for two or three years
the results could only be great um if
you fail it's only because you failed
but i see all those kids there's a kid
from there a little indian kid that quit
he was a doorman he's got a great
podcast now he's just shot something i'm
seeing these kids branch out so if
you're thinking of getting into comedy
you're thinking of getting into a band
you're thinking of drawing pictures
whatever the [__] you're thinking of
drawing remember it'll be a lot much
better for you
later
if you do that work now a lot of people
like i don't need to do that i'm better
than that okay but it's going to come
back to launch in the ass
in the words of pennzoil you can either
pay me now
or you can pay me later and but you will
[__] pay me you will [__] pay me
and that's why when i had the option of
doing the hard work and the heavy
lifting i didn't run from it guys
don't ever run from it there's no shame
in it and whatever art you pick sucking
dick stand up playing the chopsticks
hitting a [__] triangle i don't give
a [__] what it is
all this [__] applies to that it's an
art and if you put the work in
you're gonna get great results but if
you consume yourself with it and jump
into that [__] ocean like a savage
and sometimes that's not good for people
because when i jumped in that ocean
that's where the blow came that's where
the [__] careless living came but who
gives a [__]
you're working on your art
so sometimes like the man said you got
to break a couple eggs to make an
omelette right you got to bring a couple
a couple eggs to make an album it's the
same thing with your life and your
career you heard that from me nobody
gave me dick anyway on today's podcast
i had carmen morales on we talk about
hbo we talk about being specs we talk
about a lot of things
i don't know what to tell you i hope you
enjoy it carmen morales
[Music]
oh [__] oh there he is oh [__]
the [__] queen of salsa
letting these [__] know on the
hbo special about celia cruz
i [__] love it how are you carmen i'm
good how are you great to see you sorry
we didn't connect before the special i
know you were in spain
eating paellas taking pictures
making fat [__] spanish guys
like me [__] drool over you yeah it
was fun i'm not gonna lie
i went to boston
it was it was great did you do any
comedy there
hell no
really you just went to i just went to
see my family and have a time of my life
was anybody is stand-up comedy a thing
in [__] space yeah yeah there's
there's definitely spots barcelona has a
pretty like small uh scene and then
there's also a smaller a small one in
madrid as well
um i mean yeah there's there's cool
places in portugal to go up there's
places to go up but
english
yeah english there's like a bunch of
expats that live there so they all go
and see the stand up in english i would
love to go there and just goof on those
spanish [__] talk like
you know it's funny how you know like
there's a
jose diaz myself which i'm from cuba and
then there's like nate diaz
who's mexican
but i think we've all come through
[__] spain at one point or another
oh okay like i don't know i don't know
essentially it's yeah the
conquistadors basically went to all
those islands um and all of south
america and like ra raped the aztecs and
made mexicans and made everybody else i
mean that's how
that's how that [__] works that's why
there's people speaking spanish and
south america it's not because they're
like you know what we like this language
just because of the conquistadors man
it was funny because when i was growing
up i was cuban but the diaz side is from
spain
so remember the valdez's were [__]
peasants from a van that's
that's where i get my balls and heart
from yeah the diaz's were from come away
they dressed in white
and they drank wine and i remember like
being a kid
and my mom going like we gotta go to
your grandmother's house
you know
after my father died i want you to have
a relationship with his mother
i went over there twice and after the
second time i told my mom something all
i remember is my mom cursing that [__]
out in the living room
yeah my grandmother they were from spain
but they were uppity people
so when i went over there she was like
oh your sneakers are dirty my sneakers
were [__] broke heads my mom lived on
that you know me being clean like take
your sneakers off and next time your son
comes here his head better be combed and
i just remember saying like my mom going
listen
next time you tell me about my kid i'm
gonna tell you something you want to
tell me about my kid have your own
[__] kid you got to get [__] in the
air i'll never forget the look on my
grandmother's face
i know she died lived
it was not a great relationship me and
my grandparents that side
and
after like two visits my mom pulled the
plug my and then my mom started cursing
her out going who the [__] did you think
you were when i was 19 to make me move
in with your family so you could teach
me how to cook for your
for your [__] dead son oh my god
you know you had some balls if i was the
lady i was then i would have told you to
eat my [__] you know what i'm keeping a
woman up okay
and all that i was like ah
you know how can your grandmother suck
my mom's [__] you know i was my head
was about to blow up
but i never saw those [__]
again i never heard from the diaz's
again
never
i mean it makes sense it seems like she
was mad about more than just her giving
you [__] about your sneakers it seems
like there might have been well there
was a little back history there but yeah
i think that it's like me i always tell
people if i had a chance again i would
have never gone on that date with that
cuban girl with a grandmother like if i
am who i am today when i was 413 if that
[__] would have said to me yeah i could
go on a date with you my grandmother's
got to come [__] your grandmother i'm
never doing that again
you know i had to go to i went to a date
with a spanish girl every time i took
her out her grandmother would come and
sit in between us
oh yeah
and then i still remember space for god
that's all yes and then she was sitting
between us through donnie and cher like
uh donnie and marie and any time we
watch tv the grandmother was sitting
between us for people who don't know
what that's like
it sucks
especially when you're 13 and have a
[__] hard dick the whole time you
know or you because you're still
you're still 13 and you want to [__]
hold hands with your girlfriend and make
it i don't know when you're 13 a grandma
[__] is just as good as the [__]
victim you're talking you know what i'm
saying you're getting great
teeth and gum that helmet to death
forget about it yeah i had a friend
whose mother-in-law had no teeth and i
would go you don't go over there in the
breakfast and let her gum that little
helmet to death joey
where's your pride where's your dignity
everybody likes to start their day off
with a smoothie who doesn't love that
that's true
it's good for you a lot of nutrients in
there it's really good to see you carmen
uh great to see you you know when uh you
hit me because you invited me to the
shooting of your special
you did you called me up and said you
know if you'd like to come over and i
was going through my
anxiety i didn't want to be around
people my covert blues i didn't want to
be all right nobody
and now a couple weeks ago i was like
yeah carmine's going to be on the carmen
carmine
podcast you know then you called me when
you were in new york to go eat cuban
food i mean you were a [__] star you
tried to get me out of the house
i found the cuban place down here dog
next time i gotta go i gotta go you
train down and i'll take and then i'll
drive you back up north that the cuban
dude from union city it's called la flor
de cuba in freehold new jersey not bad
and the guy finally came out of the
kitchen and started talking to me we
know the same people he invited me to
his house and colt's neck so
i think i'm gonna uh get myself some
nice little cuban friends he's a hunter
oh yeah that's a cuban man that's a
hunter he's 61 he says he hunts on his
own property
then he smokes cigars drinks rum and
cooks whatever the [__] he hunted
yeah
that sounds awesome
a cuban ted nugent
without the [__] hating the democrats
and [__] yeah
my uh my dad my dad was actually when
when he immigrated here they lived in
union city in new jersey or like a lot
of cubans went there that's that was the
number two spot in the country for
cubans and listen
if i don't know if you went to union
city last time you were here like i
would i was i was
definitely going to meet you on 54th
54th
it was a nightmare that week before i
got to phone it was like every day it
was something and then it was like the
week leading up to it like the minute
from from when i got to new york until
after we finished filming it was like
uncut gems it was just one thing after
another after another i got a needle in
my foot i like lost my phone it was just
like one thing the dress that i was
supposed to wear for the special didn't
show up until like 6 15 when we started
filming at seven
you know what i'm saying it was just
like thing after thing after thing and
like it was just
there was so much [__] that went wrong i
mean it all worked out at the end
finally but you know it was just uh
nothing but stress so
but i still got to go to peter lugar so
i felt good about that good was peter
lucas oh it was
amazing they chop it up for you in
little chunks right there i was gonna go
and i got scammed because they shot a
[__] oh my god [__]
peter luga about a year ago four months
before i was there they showed up they
shot a [__]
steak is great but it ain't [__]
worth getting shot over right
you want in the afternoon right
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't get a
table at night it's like [__] unless
you know i couldn't anyways i had shows
right you had shows
and all that [__] so i was very happy
for you that you got the whole flavor
and that would have been great like to
compliment
peter lugas with a little [__]
cuban food walk around union city i
would have showed you all there's not
even any cuban spots anymore oral yeah
listen it's all apocalyptos you know
it's like uh south american
they're all mixed there's some cuban in
there mixed but
not really and like the people said the
cuban that are coming over now are not
the same cubans we grew up with
it's a different breed that's coming
over there you know everybody
the way things are over there it's it's
awful
i mean i get it they're legitimately
fleeing from cuba because like things
are horrible there right now they cut
off the internet for the whole island so
these people couldn't tell the rest of
the world that they're just murdering
their kids in the street and stuff like
that and they fall
no meat
no meat they're vegetarians now by
[__]
like by necessary it's just my necessity
i'm sorry not by choice because you go
to jail for your fish yep if they catch
you fishing you go to jail that's the
best fish in the world that water is
unpolluted
and there's the dirt the meat isn't
enough for the people now
so the meat just goes to the government
and you know some big shots
everybody else lives on eggs milk
yep rice you gotta know a guy you gotta
know a guy that knows when the truck is
coming and this is like probably once or
twice a year when there's there's a
chicken truck coming and then you have
to you have to know the guy it's almost
like you're buying stolen goods you got
to know the guy you got to bring your
little book and just hope i hope you get
some titty meat or hope you get some
kind of chicken you know it's uh it's
rough dude it's it's real rough that's
why anytime anybody somebody immigrates
dude it's [__] awful well biden
reopened it up again yesterday
oh [__] really said yeah cubans what
trump closed biden opened up now so
now cubans could go back and now my
sister died in february so i got in cuba
my sister died in february yeah and i
had no [__] way to go back down there
no
and they they bury them quick next day
max two days like it's it's it's so fast
too they don't [__] around in cuba no
they gave her a week
they gave her a week and she died in a
week
my uncle said if they couldn't fix her
like cuban medical system isn't designed
for you to go home with a pill
no well they don't have they just don't
have the equipment they don't have
that's the thing too they don't have so
when they send you home
they send you home healthy like you're
[__] healthy like that they don't
want to just put a band-aid on it with a
pill so he told me because if you're
gonna live
she'll live but if they gave her seven
days the cuban doctors are on the money
they're like [__] tremendous so
you know
it's something a sorrow that you live
with if you're an immigrant from
anywhere you know whether you're from
iran look at the people that came all
from ukraine running in the middle of
the [__] night yeah you know being an
immigrant is [__] tough you know when
uh
listen being a human being in today's
world is [__] stuff
forget about a [__] immigrant but
you know i was confused carmen because i
kept seeing
when the special came out may
5th it's may 6th yes
i saw that it was like you and robles so
i'm like what are they doing does she
have this 15 minute special
a 30 minute special and then hbo
gave her like a half hour with edwin uh
with mr robles to [__] explain like
a spanish [__] world i didn't know
what it was
no we both did fifteens we both did
that's great yeah you look beautiful
you look [__] beautiful and have you
gotten a lot of calls from it i mean
what's your expectations from it i mean
uh it's been a week so it's like it's
been like a pretty like a
like a slow trickle as far as like uh
internet stuff it's just people have
just more and more people are like
discovering it which is cool like hbo
has done a really nice job of their
placement like when you go to the comedy
section i'm right there you know well i
went and i saw a [__] other guy's
hour but i didn't see yours
actually [__] you know oh you had to
look for it i looked for it and i was
pissed to had you ride carmichael
special out
but they didn't have yours and it's
asian pacific month you know what the
[__]
i mean if you're not going to have
comment on you can't have a brother on
there either
so i thought they're gonna have like
that fan on there or chin ling doing a
[__]
chopstick trick i didn't [__] know
and then i went looking for you and i
gotta tell you it was shot beautifully
you look yeah i really like the colors
they they did a good job they did it in
a in like a in the chelsea music hall
which was in a basement and we had like
100 people so it was small because i
talked to the producer about it and it
was like i think originally was going to
be a like a more of a theater space but
he was like i i was he he asked me about
it and was like um
and i was like i'd rather have it in a
like a
a club space like that low ceiling i
want to i want this but i want to feel
feel comfortable for the first big thing
i do and that's my element you know so
um i'm so glad that they did it at the
chelsea music hall and yeah it's got the
exposed pipes and stuff and it's really
like well lit i i loved it i loved the
way it looked and it felt like a party
in there which made it even better it
made it more fun yeah i don't like
perfection of the special yeah i don't
want everything to be just right because
everybody knows that's not a special
right when i think of stand-up comedy i
think of you on stage
telling your hard
work materials for eight months on
stages here there and also no waitress
drops of glass
so your comedy goes out the [__]
window you know so i always say
i like you know that's why i don't do
well in specials but i've always loved
the listening aspect of a comedy
like right now we don't know what where
specials are going anymore i don't know
what netflix is going to do they don't
want to be woke these people awoke we
don't know what the thing is of [__]
special is going to be and the way i'm
kind of happy because
that means people go back to those
albums again i love vinyl stand up oh
yeah i [__] love it i still buy vinyl
now i still there's something about
you could listen to pryor on youtube
that's great you listen to pry you know
well the same i said
but when you put that [__]
turntable on and you put that needle on
and the album is a little old and you
hear those couples those little cracks
cracks in between and you know that just
it still does something to me because
that's how i fell in love with stand-up
comedy i didn't go to live comedy i
never went to a live show before i got
on stage really never never never wow
never didn't like it never went on a
date like that i didn't [__] stand up
i went to new york coke i don't go
uh
eddie murphy and all that [__] i never
get there like we've spent 150 for you
know they went to the garden and went to
dinner the 50 you spent that's a grammar
blow in my world i don't want to see
nobody yeah myself but i always listen
to those albums or watch it on tv i
never really saw it live
so that's why i like when i watch a
special it's like
you know it's like some are really good
some i don't know what they're doing i
think they went away from the special
they showed the audience too much for a
while i don't know what's going on with
specials no more but yours was pretty
[__] impressive i liked it well i
think what helps is the editor that did
it is um he's also a stand-up fan so a
lot of times you just get a dude who's
doing a job but this dude like loves
stan like he followed me we went to the
cellar and we went to the stand and we
went to all these places in new york and
he was just like oh my god like he was
just like a genuine fan of stand up so
then i was like oh then i would talk to
him
you know about it and stuff like that
and talk about like because he would ask
me about specials and i was like i hate
when they ruin
the art that we do by the way that they
cut it you know because sometimes they
cut away when you're making a face or
whatever and all that stuff is like like
a facial expression could be a punch
line you know so without that kind of
like mindfulness i was like i think it
can steal the essence of something
really cool that's happening
and i thought he did a great job i
really did um i mean there wasn't very
many there wasn't it was a tiny place so
there wasn't very many options as far as
like you know you cutting to the
audience or something like that like
there's there wasn't room to have a jib
in there or whatever you know so it's uh
they were like limited so it was gonna
be mainly us which i i was also fine
with i was like you can hear people
laughing
and usually they only cut to the
audience if there's a [__] up you know
if somebody messed up or they got a
reshoot or you know they're cutting from
the second show or whatever um but they
basically took my entire they didn't
edit anything out i think they edited
out maybe 30 seconds so you're seeing my
entire set so there's nothing
old porno or something like that exactly
let me ask you something because uh as
you've been i don't know if you've
noticed i know you don't give a [__]
you're like me
there's been a lot of controversies with
specials and whatnot so let me get to
this
how many years have you been doing
comment
uh 16 now
16. was it a hard 16 was it has it been
like for me if you say to me joe how
long have you been doing comment on
paper i started in 91 but not really
right i started in 91 but i knew what i
was doing in 93.
sure it took me two years of putting
around and telling people to stand up
and you know
bombing and [__] like that to realize
what my goal was
how to work it
you know everybody says oh you should
take five years to do a special six
years to do a special everybody has
their own thing for you it took 16 years
yeah finally have you put a cd out
before this
or this no i never did that i was always
just working all the time so i was just
never thinking about that like i was
always just thinking about getting
better i wasn't thinking about marketing
it which is you know to my detriment but
so that's why when it's like
oh you know like now i i know i'm going
to get the the up and coming and the you
know the new face and all this other
stuff and it's like [__] i've been
around this is just the first time you
noticed you know
that's kind of weird and you put the
work in carmen the reason why you're on
this podcast is because you know and i
told people
i get people calling me all the time
everybody always has a story in that
light everybody's got it not anymore but
when i was in la full time even before
the podcast and stuff
there's always a story
there's always somebody who comes around
you that tries to make you feel bad
for you
making moves
and they'll come to you and cry and tell
you how nothing's going on for them
the manager's not helping them this this
that you know
i never heard you complain
i got no complaints i saw you at the
store picking up garbage cans
[__] [__] garbage cans
and
i know no woman wants to be carrying out
garbage cans at a [__] box no that's
your [__] job we saw dick so you
could take out the trash
and it's like when people said to me we
don't understand how you got so big from
being a a lifter and a guy who how did
you get to be 418 well when you get to
l.a
you fall in love with something you fall
in love with your other comedy
and you know what like they say like
metallica said nothing else matters
nothing else [__] matters yeah
exactly you don't care about your health
all you care about is sleeping you get a
bag of chips before you walk at night
you know when we go to the store there's
no food there until now
yeah that was peanuts or something like
that yeah yeah i read a book with
kennison and carla bo would eat all the
bar fruit
the bartender would go stop eating the
bar fruit because they were so brutal
they'd have to cut more of it yeah they
don't want to do it
because
you know there's some people who said
you know what i could do the comedy
thing i'm the funniest guy but i don't
know about not struggling i can't do it
this ain't for you
yeah
i hate i hate when people say that
because then they don't respect um the
work that actually it comes to sure
anyone can make people that already love
them laugh
now like we have to convince people not
only to laugh but to pay attention
and to
allow themselves to have a good time
because they're all coming from various
places various jobs i can't tell you how
many times i've had like a a cop come up
to me after the show and say that they
had to watch a little kid get shot to
death today and for like a moment during
the show they got to forget about that
like that's the kind of [__] you're
never gonna i'm never gonna forget did
you do that with your friends well i'm
so funny go [__] yourself you know what
i'm saying it's not uh it's not
it's easy because we're good at it when
you see people that are good at it it
looks easy because that's how good we
are at it but anybody that's ever gone
to an open mic you can see how [__]
brutal this [__] really is we're just
talking about open mics on monday
mornings podcast
that some people to open mics to see the
train wreck yeah yeah everybody has a
different reason to go to an open mic
you know as a spectator yeah some people
want to see comedy in the purest of
purest forms which i really like i like
that you know i tell people all the time
especially now that i've been here for a
while and i can look back i like to
struggle more
than i go into the store and people like
joey what you know i didn't like that
for a while
i like going up there with people like
what time is your spot 12 45
oh you're there at nine just to see if
you get a fall out and go home and catch
you please
please somebody showed up everybody
shows up and you're gonna be there till
two in the [__] morning those are the
things that i forgot about until i got
here i really enjoyed the struggle
like the struggle you know leaving the
store at three and going to pink dot
and sharing a sandwich with duncan
yeah because that's all the money we had
you know yeah and for two drinks or
something we used to eat those meatball
sandwiches
[__] delicious the turkey i mean you
know every night that was our late
dinner was the store there was no
standard hotel
a blue burger you know it was the f you
know that struggle
the best time you'll ever have is the
open mic struggle in your hometown for
you it might have been florida oh yeah
when you're in west bomb or up north
orlando is in the middle you know when
you're starting out at some [__] bar
the banner yeah with a banner and then
you move into like a [__] saturday
remember the first time oh saturday oh
yeah i was a big wig i got to do a guest
spot you couldn't [__] talk to me the
whole next week at oprah mike's you're
on cnn with the phone on mondays mr
c.a.a i did 18 strong at the orlando
improv the other night and they're like
call me back when you got three hours
[__] three hours that's a lot of work
yeah it is
[Laughter]
my favorite is when people first start
and they go oh i have like hours of my
tea i've been writing since i was like
15 and it's just like yeah just because
you had a funny thought doesn't mean you
were writing
or the bazooka gum always had a joke on
it too or the end of a popsicle stick
i've not seen [__] bazooka gum in a
while here i got to get some [__]
bazooka gum
good luck that shit'll break your teeth
it'll pop out your molars be careful but
that [__] is good for [__]
because it strengthens your gums
with a piece of hard gum and see where
the jaw is at if the jaw's not [__]
coalition
drop her off and [__] him then you go
dutch then you go dutch and you go home
but i'm really proud of you man i like
what you've been doing
every week you're out there [__]
slinging dick at the loony bins and
[__]
comedy caravans you know uh
that's a lot of respect from me man you
know no complaining
and all you hear is like you know
females nobody gives me a spot you know
it's very nice to see a female that just
took the bull by the horns and ran with
that [__] yeah
i mean that's it that's always my move
with everything yeah
so i really appreciate you man i
appreciate you made some time for me
today
absolutely you're [__] great carmen
and uh i really was happy when you went
to spain and that made me happy after
that conversation because you took it as
a trip
yeah you took a trip you did everything
you had to do you shot your special
and now it's time to
see life again so i could write more
yeah and i didn't i did it was also like
i booked it in january and then in
february my sister passed away and of
course like it was like so that was like
i was like i don't know if i should go
you know then i just started feeling
guilty about going anywhere or like and
but it it helped so much like because
there's like you know i'm certain you
know you have you have family that you
like and that you love
and then there are certain people in
your family that you just [__]
connect with where you know what i'm
saying and i don't know if this is like
some ancient spain [__] in my lineage
where i'm just like we [__]
we [__] get each other you know and
um
that's kind of how it was and like we it
was there was plenty of unspoken like at
one point where we were both [__]
hammered drinking um
just drinking rum all night my cousin
goes hey i want you to know that i know
that you're sad um but and you we don't
have to
talk and i want you but i don't want you
to think i don't know
and um
but i want you to be able to try
to
remember
how to feel outside of the pain that
you're in
and
that was the whole thing is like because
i don't i don't talk about it i don't
want to talk about it it's not really
how i deal with it all
the the day i started feeling good about
it was the day i started talking about
it on stage or i saw because i was it
was like two months or almost a month
and a half before i saw like another
comedian friend of mine somebody i felt
comfortable with and i immediately was
like joke joke joke joke joke joke
because it was just all
family and stuff like that and you can't
be like that you can't be a comic all
the time um otherwise then your family
ostracizes you you know because you end
up being a dick because it's the
funniest thing you could have said at
that moment
you know so i try to be conscious of
that and so then it was like it was such
a relief for me because i was being a
support for my mom you know because
that's the worst pain anybody could ever
go through the worst pain and it's
unimaginable so it was like i was kind
of like helping her
bear that burden
and then you know and then i see a
comedian and i'm like oh my god you
gotta [__] i'm gonna talk to so much
[__] about myself and you know i start
saying it and then i'm now here my
catharsis is happening now me and other
people laughing about the these these
silly thoughts that i have about her and
stuff like that
makes me feel better you know it just
genuinely does and so it's like uh the
[__] like i guess that's why i'm i don't
know
as far as the spectrum goes i feel like
i'm pretty in the middle as far as like
being socially conscious and being
annoying you know in that like um i
think i should be able to talk about
[__] anything i want to ever i do i
genuinely think that um
is it always gonna be the right thing or
the like you know like the career like
not even the correct but the most
the most um
i guess conscious thing or like the most
um but the only way you get to those
places is by figuring it out and
sometimes you're figuring it out on
stage and
definitely for me because i don't write
i don't write i i'm bullet points and i
figure it all out on stage and i record
it and then listen back that's how i do
it so it's like
um sometimes you're going to be wrong
because
you're just thinking all the thoughts
and seeing which one is the one that
makes the most sense and i think
sometimes when people
will watch stand-up or they'll see a
leaked video or something they're seeing
something that's incomplete and then
judging you on that like if you ever see
somebody
painting in the park or something like
that they're in the middle of working on
something and then this if you looked at
that and you're like oh that's [__] well
yeah it's not [__] done
why don't you let me finish cooking it
before the gallery [__] yeah
exactly wait till it's hung on the wall
yeah
[Laughter]
well i gotta be honest with you you know
i think back to my life i think about
when i found my mother on the floor
the first thing i did i cracked a joke
you know i got left back i never told
her
and i kept thinking to myself i'm never
gonna have to tell i got left back
and i found her on the floor and the
first thing i said to myself was [__] i
never had to tell her about getting left
back i knew
and then it all hit me and a couple
weeks ago now i was 79 yeah it was
november in 1979 then i did something
two weeks ago here i had a guest on the
podcast and it was my mother's
anniversary of being dead
it was her birthday may 9th and i said
happy birthday to my mom in hell and it
was a stupid joke
and that night i felt bad because i had
said that on the podcast but i go no
i'm still a comic
yeah because that was i went to the
immediate thing that a comic does he
heals himself with the yes with the
[__] thing whether it's putting a
band-aid on it or
pushing it in the back
we heal ourselves we don't want to think
about that right now when i found my mom
for the first 10 minutes i was like what
do i do
what do i bet ahead might take a lot
what do i do
after the ambulance took her and i was
sitting there i started crack that's
when it started hitting me
and then the jokes weren't that good
anymore of course that's when but a
comic's life is fueled a comic's
material is fueled by pain
that's why it's great to be a comic
because when something good happens you
can talk about it
and when something bad happens when
you're ready and you have the balls
you could talk about it
i.e lesson number one from the great mr
doug stanhope
doug stanhope taught me that in 1997.
when something good happens
go out there you got your dick sucked
she had a missing tooth ha ha
ha ha my mother got in every type of
death i want you to know this and for
the people at home and i don't give a
[__] unless you're a [__] woke woke
woke woke
in every death you could stop and go
like yes every death whether elvis
[__] himself on the toilet okay and
i loved elvis the same thing you know so
when you go to awake like my first like
if i come like if i find out your dad
dies
somebody goes carmen's dad died i'm
gonna come up to your store and go come
and you got a minute i don't want to
bring it up here but i'm really sorry
about your dad and you'll hug me and
when i pull away
i'm looking at your
eyes all right
and if you're okay
i'm going to take a pause you're going
to go thank you joey i'm still whatever
proud and i go okay and then i'll take a
pause for like three minutes and i go
what's the story with the will what are
we getting
that's how i know that you're a comic
that's a real comic yeah the guy that
has the balls to say that to you yeah
because that motherfucker's gonna look
at you and go joey they ju
[Music]
because it's true
look at my grandmother's dress oh my god
look at look at look you know when my
mother's awake i was making fun of
everybody to myself look at this [__]
puke with purple shoes on look at this
[__]
i would make jokes at the casket and
[__] like that it was just like this
[__] would never wear this shade i
don't know who fact-checked this
people say to me well i'm going through
a rough patch i can't do stand-up right
now you're a [__]
because this is when i'm out there
talking about all that [__] and if you
watch stan hope's early work
he tackled a lot of his pain it was
[__] hilarious i mean one time
i knew stan hope's mom
with the fake tits from 1930 the whole
thing the wooden tits
she was a great lady she used to [__]
you could tell where doug came from when
you met her immediately not in a funny
way but in a wise guy type of way
and uh
i'll never forget that she had like 18
cats did you know that story no she
lived next to doug in hollywood
it was her and doug and doug lived and
doug had ralphie may in the house with
him
so they would torture dug his mother all
day and one day they went over there and
they saw that one of the cats died you
think mrs stanhope called the cops or
anybody no
she took a beer she took the tv off the
stand and put a towel on it and put a
shoe box and put a sheet on that and
then put the cat on there now this cat
is dead so all the other cats could say
goodbye to her guys this is legit check
the duck stand hope podcast when we did
it okay so
she had all the other cats because she
adopted cats that were missing an eye
missing a foot missing a leg didn't have
a tail they got hit by a car so she had
like six cats standing around with
slings on and [__] and they're looking
at this cat going hey
use that leg i can use that i can use
that here
so we i never forget telling doug that
for the first time we were on radio in
boston
i go doug i
you know called your mom to
say something about the cats and he's
like yeah she's really upset i said doug
did you see the wake she did
right there both of us were like wow
because nobody ever wants to bring it up
you know he wants to be the [__]
insensitive one yeah but that's what
makes a comic
yeah we don't have this because that's
the whole thing is we're observing it
all and then the we take the funny part
out of the whole thing and then we go
look at this isn't this hilarious and
then and it is
and it doesn't mean it's not def it's
not you know it's not deaf like defaming
whoever we're talking about or the
situation or making any sense we're just
laughing at the funny part of the
situation you know
you know i was thinking about my knee
surgery when i woke up it was two hours
longer than what it was supposed to be
and when i woke up dog i woke up with
nothing but pain and no dick
because if you think the cold water
makes your dick disappear pain will make
your dick
disappear walls included it just
just yelling like i wish i had footage
of me just yelling
going what the [__] is this pain and
like hold on hold on we're gonna shoot
you with something but we gotta go back
in your leg and turn off the nerve i'm
like what oh what what the [__] are you
talking like you know i wish i would
have had footage of me then because i
was crying i wasn't just yelling like a
man i was crying yeah you're a [__]
[__] you know yeah but i think about
that moment i'm laughing because
that if you can't laugh at yourself
you're [__] done i love laughing at
any i don't give a i saw [__] mickey
whatever don rickles getting beat up the
other day on [__] casino
hits him up with the phone and he goes
down he's laying like he looks like a
[__] he looks like a lizard down the
floor and [__]
you know and you can't laugh at that but
you do that's what life is all about
that we [__] take a minute and laugh
at ourselves
and that you know what when something
bad really dies that you could still
take a minute and go wow
this is funny and you don't have to tell
nobody people
nobody's going to say well how can you
think of that a moment like this well
i'm trying to [__] put a little
levity into the phone yeah
just trying to make it
palatable you know trying to make this
as pine as [__] painless as possible
and [__]
so what are your plans for the future
talk to me what do you got going on
well um i'm i'm hoping that maybe this
turns into a half hour since it's being
so well received i know it was telling
into a half hour and that's what i liked
about the 15 minutes
that it's enough but it's not enough
yeah
yeah that's all i'm open
yeah i think that 15 minutes is enough
for me to fall in love with you
i think the hour was special
you still do it as a headliner because
we want to flex our hour muscle one time
of course yeah if you think about the
whole situation think about the whole
special viewing process
think about how you view specials
when you're on the move i don't have a
whole hour to watch a special unless i'm
on the road in a hotel room on a
saturday or friday night
if i'm here no with the kid walking
upstairs and my wife asking me how i am
i i can't watch a [__] special
you can't watch the special in focus you
know yeah
so that's why i think like sometimes a
15 or 30 minute special is [__] just
enough man yeah and it keeps them
wanting more which is the most important
thing well because stand up it's like
it's not like you could just put on a
movie in the background you have to act
you have to actively listen and it's
difficult to ask people
to actively listen to anything for an
hour because there's always
notifications on everything the
microwaves going off all the coffee's
done somebody's calling me
what's the what is that why is why is my
face time going off there's always some
[__] happening that's always just
there's constant distractions so i think
shorter form like i'm still a old-school
purist and i love an hour because i love
an arc i love taking people on a journey
and all that [__] that's my favorite and
i have an hour ready you know but the i
will
do a half hour that's going to have
nothing to do with the hour because it's
like i also at the end of the day like
most people are gonna consume it in clip
form they're gonna watch it a minute to
two minutes at a time you know so um
i also understand that and i'm okay with
that too it's just then the people who
are
really into it like the people who like
stand up like that when they have an
hour they will they'll go to youtube and
watch joe list or something like that
they'll go and watch an hour and seek it
out you know um
but i think you're right for the most
part people are just trying to watch it
as much as they can and it's usually
passive it's usually like
15 30 minutes at a time you know
yeah how they treat you
they're it's
it's great it's really great um i think
i think um i think emily's doing a
wonderful job the vibe there is super
fun
the vibe there is super fun and uh it's
awesome i love the [__] store
always in forever i mean that place has
been so kind to me and
i feel like i'm part of comedy history
there and so i they'll always have my
loyalty for sure i never did [__]
but i'm part of the comedy store history
and that's all that [__] matters to
me
[__]
any dates coming up that you want to
push on here oh my god i have uh i have
a bunch of them actually i'm going to be
oh it's all over the place i'm going to
seattle i'm going on the road with
funches for a little bit
that's not a [__]
one of those whoopee bags that's a
syringe
listen i already got had gotten a needle
in my foot during the
listen i'm all right i'm fine you're
ready to go i'll go and if anything that
just means free drugs you know there's
like some residue left there so more
drugs i didn't have to buy
but it's a good high but you have to
take a tetanus shot so that's a
[__] right there
it's the shot that requires a second
shot
where can they find you where's your
website at carmen
carmenmorales.com for all of your carmen
morales needs um follow me on all the
assorted social media at thefunnycarmen
and um yeah please uh please check out
it's called entrenos is the name it's
kind of like a a latinx uh
you know comedy central presents where
they take a and the thing i think
actually i did want to talk to you about
this is the thing that i liked about
these producers that are making these is
it's not all just
letting people be like type of [__] you
know it's it's not just diver it's not
diversity in in the sense of like
just put a bunch of spiks together like
it's not like that at all it's a
diversity of thought so you have you
know people who are super quiet and like
are you know clean and stuff and you
have people that are like loud and big
energy and like talk about their family
and people that you know that are just
quirky and like it's just look look at
how diverse
latin people are and like it's not just
you know like i'm certain you did
especially around los angeles that like
refried comedy and stuff like that where
they just want a particular it was
almost like the chitlin circuit for
latin people is basically what it was
and that's like it was like you know
it's and that's like what a lot of
promoters and stuff like that we're
looking for but what i loved about um
the producers edwin and victor what i
loved about both of them is they wanted
genuine diversity which is like a
diversity of thought which is like
people with different perspectives uh
people with different walks of life
different kinds of latin people you know
and um and that's the thing that they've
done that that
they've done great i mean like
they helped prop up ida who's like one
of my absolute and utter favorites like
she's such a bad [__] oh my god
she's amazing
and um
her and i always talk about you which is
funny yeah when she ate the edible and
ended up in the hospital
i didn't even know she called me the
next station i was in the hospital
what [__] [__] are you talking
about you just ate an edible and went
home but i could tell when i crooked i
thought you know her eye just went
and you could tell that this edible
is not working the right way for my love
i love her too another hard-working
[__] savage so
i'm proud of you guys man this is what
it is everybody thinks it's the [__] oh
you're gonna go on the rogan but listen
you gotta do your work for [__] rogan
forget the tonight show forget a netflix
special
you gotta do the [__] work and you
could cry all you want about
not getting spots and this and this and
i'm gonna point my finger to carmen
morales and ida
funny ida and felicia who never
complains she's she just started a new
show rage against the machine this [__]
edge against the machine she was out
there [__] bitching at people
i like all this stuff man so i'm really
happy i miss you guys with all my art oh
i missed my comedy store girls whitney
was just here when he hit me up last
night tuesday night monday night it
whitney hook hit me up you ready for
this yeah she was at a fox party
with one of my nephews
this kid this kid i've been throwing
this kid when he was five i threw him up
in the air i forgot there was a pipe
up [__]
i never thought he was gonna be okay he
gave him one of those little dents in
the back yeah this [__] is a big
time executive for fox
nick
nikki t like i knew him and his bro his
father saved me from drugs in 85 his
father moved me in and instead of me
going to a rehab helped me out and now
today that kid's son
is a big shot at fox and he called me
once a week ago i heard your name today
it made me proud
[Laughter]
so that's how i miss whitney i miss you
i miss eliza i miss a lot of you [__]
dude i miss you coming there and
watching you work out too like that's
the other thing too is like because i
was i wasn't in la for like a year
because i was with my folks you know and
that was like probably what i missed the
most is like being able to constantly be
around it whether you're not going up or
whatever just because like the the
energy i think and the it's just like
watching people think things through and
how how they're like you know all of
that [__] is just so inspiring to me i
just love being around it on this
channel next on tuesdays and thursdays
tripoli
and this [__] the little jewish kid
who was getting [__] funny towards
the end he went up before me on a
saturday
and i'm like i'm going to follow this
[__]
you see these little guys you know
because i would want to do the early
spots those early those are those young
[__] killers you know they ain't
[__] around down there at the store
and i'm going i'm gonna follow this
[__] kid he's up there jumping and
dying
you know so i missed the whole
thing and hopefully uh they offered me a
movie i was supposed to be in la
tomorrow but it was just the 19th and
then june 10th
one day yeah that's gonna fly out for
the 19th
and then either sit around or come back
on june 10th
i don't know if you've seen the price of
plane tickets they're not [__] it's
insane dude i just had to cancel a gig
because the flight was more than i was
getting paid for the [__] gig yeah
it's insane i'm not cheap but you know
what man if you know how many times i i
spent like 800 on like a late ticket
like you would call me and go joe i got
this show
you know and i go listen carmen don't
worry about the plane ticket i got so
many miles and [__] you know when you
got miles a 600 plane thinking ain't
gonna kill you you pay
i just saw april macy got a 700 ticket
for four dollars you know
but when i don't have my i still got
some miles on some people but
the tickets i saw to go to la and again
it's going to be a loser deal no matter
what yep i'm getting 650 a day right
that's scale for sag whatever yeah
49 a day
you know they're not going to hit ice
that's not that's not even going to
cover your flight out there that's what
i'm saying like and i would do it for
the guy he put me in two movies before i
really liked him i liked his writing it
wasn't about any dog you know what was
in the movie was the black guy that
narrates everything
in the [__] movie i just wanted to do
the movie for him just
and i was like again i want to go to la
i need to go to the ice cream shop i
need to
stop by the store and see some people
but i can't take a fifteen hundred
dollar loser
yeah because it was uh what do you call
that it's a local hire
so for people who don't know what a
local hire is you're in a union you pay
them dues
you pay [__] yearly dues and
quarterly dues
and then they come out with these movies
that they pay you to do the work but
they don't pay you for your plane ticket
or your hotel
and i really did that with a movie and
then but i talked to tom papa once and
he's like joey i did three movies where
i just broke even
i just waited for residuals i prayed on
the residuals being good
i just couldn't do it this time i i saw
the amount of that plane ticket and i'm
like you know what i don't want my
the hotel well then also if you stayed
in los angeles dude that's like that's
like a few weeks you gotta put you gotta
put you know that's a lot of money
catch me on the next one and he was like
that's cool you know so i'm gonna go to
i gotta go to austin next month and i'm
doing a couple dates with rogan here and
a couple dates with burton
then i'll evaluate comedy i'm doing too
much with my daughter now to go out on
the weekend so i'm happy about that [__]
i can't be doing what i was doing
anymore i don't even think i could do a
late show that 10 30 [__] [__] you
that's why you're the perfect person for
someone like me to work with because
then i'll headline the late show
that's a great idea love that
split week [__] i love that idea oh wait
i love you carmen thank you very much
for taking the time i love you too
thanks so much i'm really [__] proud
of you you [__] savage cubans
[__] still at the store knocking out
of the park say hello to everybody for
me i will love you and i'll be in touch
carmen morales thank you for taking the
time thanks for having me
any time
love you guys thank you
bam
uncle joey's back [__]
we had a nice little chit chat i don't
know if it's up your [__] alley if it
is
thank you for watching if not i don't
know what to [__] tell you you know
what i'm saying
that's a real [__] woman that's what
you want a woman to be nowadays right
you want them to work you want them to
get equal opportunity you want them to
be excited about it that's carmen
morales she ain't crying i swear to god
i've known her for years she's never hit
me with an excuse
never give me no [__] about i don't
know i'm not getting spots well carry
the garbage they'll give you spots and
she did it and that's why she got a
special so stop your [__] crying
strap on a pair of [__] nuts and go
for it whatever your plans are whatever
your dreams are they're available to you
stay black i love you and i'll see some
of you tomorrow night at uncle vinnie's
the rest of you [__] i'll see you
next monday tip top magoo stay black and
now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right you [__] savages i want to
thank carmen morales i want to thank you
[__] i want to thank mike lee i
want to thank everybody for having my
back
but most importantly i want to thank my
sponsors expressvpn like i told you in
the beginning of this podcast i talk
about vpn all the time they are [__]
tremendous they help you protect your
online activity
from these [__] that are spying
on you trying to profit off you and
track you but there's actually another
reason why many listeners love
expressvpn you get streams from other
[__] countries thousands of shows on
netflix are only available outside the
us so you need to change your country to
see them expressvpn reroute your data
through a server location of your choice
and lets you control which country you
want to watch netflix to think you're in
choose from over 90 countries so every
time you run out of stuff to watch [__]
it you fire up the app what's going on
in bulgaria this [__] week and that's
just not on netflix that's what
everything you could with expressvpn you
could unlock other streaming services
too and you could dive deep into the
dark web of the underworld
look there's a reason why expressvpn is
number one rated vpn provided by
publishers of the verge and your uncle
joey visit expressvpn.com right now
slash joey
j-o-e-y right now and get three months
extra months
of their service for free that's it free
expressvpn.com
joy i'm gonna give you three extra
months
of their service for free just like that
so go to expressvpn express
joey to learn more
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my personal [__] favorites my do
or dyer my ride
cbd lion the best whether you get the
capsules
the kinesiology tape the [__] cream
i mean listen they're the number one in
my world why they've been with me for
three years
you guys know i wouldn't have kept them
around i'm an old man and they helped me
in every aspect of my [__] game you
could even get the bad balls forget
about it just go to the cbd lion
read the third party lab results read
all about cbd
cbn cbo cby get educated and then order
something
put code joey joint or church and get 20
off your first order do not forget about
those delta nines they'll put you in
another [__] dimension if you get 20
off on the delta knight it's a
tremendous [__] deal so knock
yourself out i want to thank cbd lion
express
vpn i want to thank onyx and i want to
thank thefreezepipe.com
i love your [__] with all my
heart stay black and i'll see you tip
top magu monday morning
you